marie stuart et condamné à mort
sur ordre de notre souveraine elizabeth
reine d'angleterre
comment en est on arrivé là
j'ai eu des nouvelles le roi françois
aimant votre cousine marie est revenue
pour régner sur les casses c'est une
femme redoutable notamment
donc elle se prépare à la guerre a dit
tout certes je commandais désarmé mais
dit à ma cousine que nous prions pour
rester en tête
j'espère que nous nous rencontrerons
pour pouvoir sceller une ode est ce qu a
regarder la vérité en face madame c'est
une prétendante à votre trône
je devrai détrôné une reine kim et
apparentés une guerre civile éclatera
soit là bas soit ici un fléau s'est
abattue sur notre terre
une femme qui porte une couronne
kandé son frère son allégeance nous est
acquise
ils n'ont pas d'appétit pour la guerre
alors ouvrons leur l'appétit ce que les
armes sont créés
c'est simplement de faire l'unité de ce
pays
mais ils veulent s'emparer de ma
couronne une meurtrière une traîtresse
et rennes mais je serai la femme qu'elle
n'est pas nous mettons au monde un
héritier au trône décosse et
d'angleterre
notre rencontre elle secrète
si vous en parlez je n'irai tous accepté
d'être la marraine de monfils accepté
d'être meilleur
marie est notre ennemi
nous ne nous inclinerons pas devant elle
comme nous le faisons devant vous
vous pouvez pas lever une armée vous
doutez souvent de ce que je suis en
mesure de faire n'entrez pas dans leur
jeu votre coeur vaut mieux que les
hommes qui vous conseille vous devriez
mesurer vos propos je refuse de me faire
tancer par une inférieurs puis
l'intérieur
[Musique]
si vous choisissez de vous tuer vous
tuerez votre soeur
et vous tuerez votre reine
comment en est on arrivé là
[Musique]